James what's the most important part of
the screen writing process for you I'm
sure it varies from narrative filmmaking
to documentary filmmaking dealing with
the anxiety just being patient and not
questioning or I mean I it may be sound
like a glib answer there for me is I
think the work I tend to do is a very
research-based and often requires
extensive other interviews or
documentation that finding documents
pens because I tend to do fact-based
work but then there's a moment when you
should gathered all this information and
you got to remind yourself that the
people that you're writing about our
humans they're real people they're not
marble statues or photographs they're
their daughters and sisters mothers sons
and that process of sort of being
patient and and not rushing and racing
something I learned in this documentary
actually I couldn't possibly right seems
like some of the scenes that occur in
real life in the film I'm not nearly as
imaginative her creator there's just no
way seen that takes place between Steve
and Mosley and Bill Genovese or when
Michael Farrar is remembering what it
was like in the vestibule 1e the first
time he stepped inside that vestibule
work after kitty had been murdered
when Bill meets with kitties lover
Marianne where the guys in the bar I
can't write that well I don't have that
kind of imagination and so if i learned
anything from this process it's to be a
better listener take my time be more
patient you know real life has so much
much more creative writer than while
certainly than i am and i think that
that has been that's the deepest most
profound impact i think on my career as
a screenwriter just to be a better
listener take my time be more patient
more open
you